[Music]
yeah so thanks for an introduction so me
Caroline and satti maybe you can just
quickly wave will tell you about what we
do here at spooking outcome in the
machine translation steam so yeah maybe
you know actually
[Music]
so booking is originally a Dutch company
but actually right now we're available
in 43 different languages and this is
also what our team actually tries to
help with so the dream of our team is we
would be able to translate like every
piece of text into from any language
into any other languages and that's so
in a nice fashion statement we was we
want to empower people to experience the
world without any language barrier so
what we'll talk about to talk about
today we got a little step closer I
guess to this dream by doing a transfer
learning both across domains and across
different languages and we'll keep the
kind of theory and minimum but we do
want to show you a little bit for the
people that are desperately thinking
like Oh what was transfer learning again
I'm gonna quote Wikipedia which says
transfer learning it's a research
problem in machine learning that focuses
on storing knowledge gains while solving
one problem or maybe on one domain and
applying it to a different but related
related problem so we'll see that both
across different domains and across
languages just keep this in mind this is
the main theme so some context the
machine translation team we exist for I
think around three three years and what
we used to focus on really is
translating a property descriptions so
we've got texts like the one you see
here the house is only a 10-minute
journey from New Castle Center and five
minutes from the Metro Center shopping
complex and you can see this really a
specific kind of text and we would
always translate from English into any
of these I think it's 11 languages I
don't know if there's any
spanish-speaking people in the room can
they check this translation maybe
yeah is it good so this is what our
motto used to do yeah okay I see a
thumbs up this night so yeah actually
the models that we used to train then we
trained it just on this in-house data
set of property descriptions so it was
just trained on this very specific
domain and actually did really well on
that domain but now comes we had a new
challenge that we also want to translate
a lot of all the user-generated context
that content that we get and an example
that is the reviews that we get so let's
say I'm Dutch so if I would write a
review I probably write it in Dutch but
actually you want all users of the
website to be able to understand what I
said so I might write something maybe in
English location is very far from the
city centre the breakfast with some
spelling mistake was poor and then yeah
maybe we can have the Spanish speaker
check again do you think yeah I mean I
can actually so if we do that through
Google Translate we can actually see
that it translated to it's very close to
the center of the city and the
restaurant was pomo some random word so
what you can see here is that actually
it was just trained on these property
descriptions which are always very
positive so like no matter what it sees
even if it's a very negative text it
will just produce something positive so
it's close to the center of the city and
also it is not able to understand this
spelling mistake although we as humans
can't like yeah kind of clearly see that
this was meant to be breakfast yeah so
what should we do
so then yeah we get back to this maybe
we can learn from different domains in
order to be able to also translate
refuse well and I should answer that
that we don't have so you serve for
property descriptions we had a big
in-house data set of parallel sentences
so we had really good training data but
for refused we had a really small
training set so not enough to to just
simply train on that so what we what we
decided to try is we will train a model
on a lot of we will called multi-domain
they
basically this is open source data like
TED Talks UN documents translated
basically everything that we could find
an idea would be to train a first model
so multi-domain model just on that and
then we would be able to find you so it
means like do a couple of rounds of
final training just on this specific
domain that we would be interested in so
we could have a general model and then
we could find units maybe on property
descriptions or on the refused maybe
even customer service emails or yeah
anything that we would have just a small
data set on yeah just to make it maybe a
bit more concrete this is what we
actually had so for English to Spanish
we had a lot of property description
training data of 15 million parallel
sentences and four reviews again way
less too few to train a model on itself
so we added a lot of yeah the open
source data and in this way we could
kind of increase our data set from this
15 million to ninety-six million
parallel sentences but it's not so clear
that so we try to translate reviews so
how much would actually legal documents
translations that talks yeah it's not
exactly the same so therefore transfer
learning so learning on a different
domain and trying to apply it to the
domain that we're actually interested in
yeah to give you some idea so the first
two examples we already saw the kind of
data that we add is yeah maybe movie
subtitles hi uncle Howard are you mad
please don't be mad and some legal texts
you've requested a debate on this
subject in the course of the next few
days during this part session it can be
very complicated thing the ocean so it's
not super related to refuse but yeah we
just gonna throw it all in and see if we
can learn from it anyway and the answer
is yes so we want to show you now XE the
results of this justice multi domain
model so it's not actually even find you
yet for the reviews these are the
results that we have a small sample that
is check check by humans and they
basically say
it's okay to go online or not and the
percentage tells you how much of this
sample is okay to go online and on this
old property description model so just
trained on the very narrow domain so on
property descriptions it did really well
like 99 percent was okay to go online
but on positive reviews and especially
on negative reviews this wasn't good
enough for us
unlike as it refuses got only 79 percent
but now in contrast we will see how it
did on the how the multi domain model
actually did so trains on all this data
we see that it got a little bit worse on
property descriptions which kind of
makes sense we add a lot of non related
stuff there it wasn't fine-tuned yet on
property descriptions but we got a big
gain on both the positive reviews and
the negative reviews which we get up to
90 points 4% so yeah we were quite happy
so yeah we want to I also want to show
you a little bit of theory of okay how
do we really do this and let's just look
at this let's say translation we want to
translate from this Spanish hola PI data
to hello PI data and now what we do is
we will start actually by splitting this
source sentence so the Spanish sentence
in two sub words so we provide in the
beginning we provide the we kind of
decide how many what are the supports
that we can use so it it's actually a
dictionary about about 30,000 sub words
and the thing to note here is that maybe
if you did other NLP related tasks such
as maybe sentiment classification or
yeah maybe any classification tasks
context and what yeah what we usually do
is actually you just use the word
themselves as features and if sometimes
there's an unknown word that you never
saw on the training data that's fine you
could maybe the model will just ignore
it but for translation you can't I mean
if you kind of miss a word then
you're never going to be able to
translate well so that's why we have
this idea of sub words that's in the
worst case if it never saw anything of
the word before it could actually fall
back to the character levels up words
so usually then the model would be able
to copy or at least still make some
sense of it and we would actually never
have unknown tokens so the kind of
models that we use is encoder decoder
models so the job of the encoder is to
understand the source so we feed a token
by token and a job of the decoder is to
kind of take that information and to
one-by-one spit out the targets tokens
so in this case it's I mean this is what
it's supposed to do so now that you know
a little bit how this actually works we
also want to show some actual
translations of this multi-domain model
that we built oh sorry I just want to
show one thing in between which is the
specific library that we're using here
at booking it's open nmt so neural for
neuro machine translation that's Python
binding so we're on the right conference
I guess so it does sequence sequence
mapping which is the thing that we use
but actually it also has other let's say
options
so maybe classification or sequence
tagging supports many architectures RNN
convolutional neural networks the one
that we're using it's a transformer so
another kind of encoder decoder
architecture and the nice thing about it
is that it's based on tensor flow so it
allows multi-gpu training and also you
have these nice monitoring on on tensor
board kind of for free so now comes to
demo I was so excited about it that I
already jumped to it and so what we want
to show you is kind of even bit more
difficult task we we will translate
using our English to Spanish model so
maybe from the house to la casa
and then we also have the model in the
reverse direction which will translate
from Spanish to English so we hope that
it actually goes from the house to La
Casa back to the house or maybe it could
give a synonym of the house so because
it's it just should understand that it's
the house but it doesn't have to give
back the exact word
so yeah let's come back to this example
where I hope we still remember that in
the old case it would translate to
something positive and it doesn't
understand the spelling mistake now now
what we see actually is that with this
double translation now it that actually
does understand location very far from
the city centre and it kind of corrected
the spelling mistake breakfast was very
poor it just actually makes it it's not
just poor but very poor but we yeah this
would be considered yeah good
translation so this is definitely way
better than what we what we had before
so this is actually satis work he wanted
to take it even to the more extreme this
is what he kind of a demo example where
this person might be very lazy he
doesn't want to type any syllables so
and also the second sentence i think
only half of the tokens actually is I
mean it's good makes some sense but
still as human we can understand what it
says here so ideally we would have a
model also just being able to translate
this and yeah this is the nice nice
example of course that actually this is
what our model did like double translate
it did understand it and it's even
corrected like this source sentence so
at least that is impressed that's good
do one more example which is mmm like I
can't work today because I'm under the
weather which is also quite difficult
for the model because this is some kind
of a saying and even here like going
from Spanish back to English it
translates it to the more literal thing
I can't work today because I'm sick yeah
so we can see that it really pays off to
like train on a lot of general data it
now really understands many more concept
than just property descriptions so here
actually I want to
ask you what could go wrong this is
great
and I will hand over to set it to kind
of so two things are while we transfer
this one is this was amazing and two is
this was also a little bit of cheating
let's see why this is a little bit of
cheating
so we said in the very beginning that we
are going to cover all 43 languages and
so far what we have looked at is our
best-case scenario we showed you for how
well things can work in case of Spanish
but Spanish is a language for which we
had largest available of sentence pairs
to train on we had 96 million sentences
with English and we could train a good
translation model which is also of a
comparable amount of size with 100
million parameters that was somehow
doable but what about the rest of the 43
languages they won't have so much data
what about this extreme a language like
Ukranian we would only have going
open-source and whatever we would only
have three million sentence pairs to
train with English on this is much of a
worst case than what we have been
looking at so far so 30 times less
training data and 30 times and assuming
that Ukrainian is no easier than Spanish
then the model capacity should still
remain the same so 30 times less
training samples versus the model that
we want to train we want to learn so
seems like a difficult task now let's
see for ourselves so now we are going to
focus on Ukrainian instead of Spanish
and we are going to look at Ukrainian to
English translation model trained
exactly the same way the Spanish way and
let's see if it works so the x axis here
is the training steps while we train the
model in increments of 40,000 steps but
I do zoom in on the first 40,000 because
a lot of interesting things happen in
those first 40,000 steps so that
timeline is zoomed in the y axis is some
measure of loss so in these kind of cuz
this is sequence level log loss but for
what it matters for a good model the
loss value should be low let's see what
happens when we train Ukrainian to
English the model gets really good after
40,000 steps or a couple of hours and
then it worsens or over fits now in
comparison the span
each model kept on getting better and
better and better on the same hardware
for four days
so maybe the mall didn't learn enough
maybe something did not happen
adequately let's see this is a Ukrainian
review that we want to translate now
using the model can I ask if there is a
native Ukranian speaker so it is a small
language can I ask can I ask if there is
a Russian speaker wonderful can you
roughly interpret what this means in
English for us so we got something oh I
don't think if this review is helpful
right now but this is what the machine
learns to translate they are not here
air conditioning is ready get warm
troops and slippers something is going
wrong in the language structure on the
first side and about this word troops on
the second side there is hope the hope
comes from transfer learning the hope
comes from the fact what we saw just now
that Ukrainian to English can possibly
benefit from Russian to English model
because Russia to English we still have
much more data and that hope hinges on
couple of facts one is for both these
translation tasks English was a common
part half of the model can actually
really benefit because it is common the
other language it definitely seems
similar just now the two languages
Russian and Ukrainian so maybe between
one model well that could somehow
benefit the other model we need to
figure out how we are going to transfer
this knowledge but there is hope
the rest of the talk is going to focus
about how we bring this knowledge from
one model to another a model a method
popularized in computer vision is to
initialize a model with another model
that you have built already which is
working with what this means in our
context is let's train a Russian to
English translation model which takes in
Russian sentences
and has already learned to translate it
into English and let's use its weights
to initialize the weights of a Ukrainian
to English translation model so all the
weights just copy pasted and then we
start the training of Ukrainian to
English translation model on it's
limited data so it has some kind of head
start now of course one catch here is of
course Ukrainian is vocabulary is going
to be different so some of those things
those embeddings and words are going to
still be initialized at random how does
this work out now we did to test not
just not only do we initialize the
Ukrainian with the Russian we actually
also initialize Ukrainian with the
French the second test now this test is
really important for us because while
Russian is a natural language of choice
for Ukrainian we also want to scale our
ideas to the rest 43 languages and we
may not have a tight pair like Ukrainian
Russian going forward so we also test
with initializing with a not so similar
language results we get better model in
both the cases language similarity of
seems intuitive helps a little further
but it is not necessary and this is good
news what happens to the translation ok
partly fixed we have pyjamas now but the
language structure is probably still
poor and it seemed like it is also poor
because in the source itself in the
Ukrainian text itself the language
structure is also a little complex so
going forward there is one thing
although about this approach that I
personally don't like it's very
one-at-a-time approach you need one good
model to begin with to benefit another
one model at a time and the benefit is
in one direction only kun ration model
have benefited from Ukrainian couldn't
there have been many languages
benefiting from Russian model all in the
same go that would be good for the long
tale of 43 languages so joint learning
the idea is one model trained jointly to
perform any translation task so Russian
to English Ukrainian to English and
whatever to English that you want to
throw in you throw in same model learns
all these translation tasks so there is
more data being thrown in the data
augmentation perspective of benefit and
there are many us being learned many
losses being minimized the model learns
to transliteration to English and
Ukrainian to English etc so the
multitask learning kind of law
see and advantage also coming it this is
a little bit of detail doesn't matter
too much fourth mattresses we are
training one model to do all these tasks
showing all those data points and this
time we do three tests the tests are
shown in green we are going to train
Ukrainian with Russian of course a
natural choice with French of course we
discussed this earlier and this time we
are also going to throw both of the in
Russian and a joint because we want to
see if the potential is not just two
molds at a time but many things being
trained together so we want to expand
how many things can be trained together
so now we have three in that set
Ukrainian Russian and French of course
we have some reference points from what
worked for us earlier the initialization
methods and not doing anything method
one thing I would highlight is a key
high key thing to note here is the
moment we start mixing doing this joint
training all of a sudden we have much
more data coming from Russian language
then coming from Ukrainian to English
language pairs so three million versus
50 million do we really want the
training the joint training to be
overwhelmed by and dominated by Russian
to English translations maybe not and
the easiest way to handle that is this
upsampling high parameter that we should
up sample and boost just duplicate those
examples of Ukrainian to English to
balance them out that is what we do
somebody else could see it as a hyper
parameter and they could tune this
mixing ratios we don't do that in the
next result that we see now oh by the
way any intuition which one is going to
work waste out of the three tests the
both if the both works well I think it
is good news so that's what I am also
hoping for because then we can think of
training nine languages together and it
does so both in blue versus or Russian
and French everything is working but
both does not be worse than just Russian
alone which is good news the other thing
I would add is versus what we got
earlier this is going to work much
slower it takes its own time verses
initialization method which converts
really fast which got best really soon
and that makes sense in initialization
what are we doing we are giving the
Ukrainian model the initial boost the
initial head start with whatever
it knew from the Russian English model
about English and about Russian and
that's all over here at the very
beginning the model knew neither Russian
nor English nor Ukrainian so it is this
interplay happening over the course of
the training where model and something
about Russian that benefits Ukrainian it
learns something about Ukrainian that
benefits Russian so of course joint
training takes its own time but then it
does get to something really nice what
happens to the translation I think it
works the last one there is no air
conditioning no here no heating so take
warm pajamas and slippers now of course
we are it like any demo we are doing
some cherry-picking but we have also
done human evaluation results and yes
this is the rank ordering of goodness of
these methods to conclude we looked at
we started this has been a long journey
no transfer learning carline showed us
that when we train spanish on our own
data it didn't do so well we naturally
try to borrow the knowledge from other
domains movie subtitles etcetera and we
saw the spanish model got amazingly
robust event to spelling mistakes and
extreme mistakes but then the moment we
came to long tail of languages ukrainian
that wasn't adequate so we had to go
further to face the knowledge from
something even further we had to face
the knowledge from other translation
tasks other languages this is what we
saw for ukrainian we saw two popular
methods of transfer learning that you're
going to send see not just in machine
translation but also it's outside which
is one is to initialize the model with
something that we think and benefit and
the other one is to train things jointly
what we saw is both methods work but
jointly was slower but even better at
this point we can take questions
you
[Applause]